yesterday it was called to my attention
that Ana Kasparian from The Young Turks
did a major takedown video against
intellectual dark web classical liberal
free speech advocate Dave Rubin as many
of you know Dave Rubin formerly was part
of the Young Turks he was also formerly
someone I spoke to on a somewhat regular
basis we even worked on a couple of
projects together when he was involved
with aura TV and I was involved with
aura TV on a web platform sort of
venture and as I think people in my
audience will attest my political views
really haven't changed much in the last
few years but Dave Rubin has become or I
guess you could say discovered that he
is a classical liberal and lately he
finds that the top truth tellers are
people like ben shapiro an extreme right
winger and others on the right and quite
frankly i don't know what dave rubin
thinks of me at this point we really
haven't spoken much since we did a
one-hour interview with him at this
point a while ago and in a piece that
ana kasparian did yesterday she cited
that interview which very quickly got
its first 125 or 150 thousand views and
it is clearly going to get a lot of
attention here is just to kind of like
set up for context the reference that
ana makes to my interview with dave
rubin in her piece rubin declares that
all decent people must fight extremes by
judging people as individuals and not as
groups and then in another video he
states it's official leftism is a mental
disorder
political commentator David Pakman even
called him out on it
you said innocent in an interview with
ben shapiro that liberalism is basically
a mental disorder what did you mean by
that I don't think I said liberalism I
might have said progressivism right it's
not surprising to me that he goes back
and forth it's not surprising to me that
he lies and spreads propaganda it's not
surprising that he has completely
flipped the switch on who he is as an
individual and what his political
beliefs are so listen I
and I used to be very close with Dave
Ruben I really don't know if Ruben
considers me anything at this point an
acquaintance a friend whatever I get a
lot of emails from the audience the gist
of which is David you know Dave Ruben
can't you set him straight on this topic
or that topic and the answer is no I
can't I can't I I have many friends with
whom I disagree with politically and
it's no problem
but I just don't think that with Ruben
it's anything like that sort of
proactive nature I think I don't cross
the guys mind and I can't set him
straight on anything and I've sort of
made an effort not to participate in the
irrational Ruben bashing and if I
disagree on policy great I mean that
that was made clear during my interview
with Dave Rubin and I was actually I've
not mentioned this story before
Pat's taking notes I was approached some
months ago by a journalist at a media
outlet that you all know and they wrote
to me and they said hey David we know
you were previously in touch with Dave
Rubin we want to interview I want to
interview the person said about Dave
Rubin and the writer said I'm also
reaching out I also reached out to Dave
Rubin to get his take and I got a
strange feeling that it was maybe a hit
piece and so I contacted Dave Rubin and
I said listen this this writer reached
out to me I'm getting a weird feeling
they say that they reached out to you I
have no problem talking to them about
policy I'm not going to just hurl at
homonyms that's not what I do but did
they reach out to you because they said
they did and Dave wrote back to me and
said they didn't reach out to me and I
think it's definitely a hit piece and I
went back to the writer and I said
listen I don't want to participate in
this because you lied to me you said you
reached out to Dave Rubin and you didn't
reach out to Dave Rubin unless Rubin is
lying to me that's the last contact I
had with Dave Rubin and that was months
ago and a couple weeks ago I sent him a
text about something not at all related
to politics he did not write back to me
and I I really couldn't tell you what
the circumstances are the most common
question I get is do I think that Dave
Rubin really had a political awakening
or is he just doing this for money
because
funded by learn liberty or whatever koch
connected organization and and the
answer is i genuinely have no idea
because it doesn't really seem like he
has any interest in in having that
conversation with me but my impression
from the contact i did have with him
after his awakening was that he really
seems to believe the stuff I don't have
any reason to think that dave rubin is
playing any kind of a character whether
he's been sort of bamboozled into taking
these positions or not i couldn't say
but all the evidence I have is that the
positions that he espouses are his
genuine sincerely held positions today's
program sponsored in part by blinkers
comm slash Pakman I've talked about
blinkers before it's this awesome app
that I've been using for several months
now and what it does is take the best
and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to be li NK is t.com slash PA k ma n